Apple's M3 family and Max are finally
getting a huge upgrade that us consumers
have been asking Apple for for literally
over seven years yes for the first time
ever Apple's base Max are likely to come
with more than eight gigabytes of RAM
which was basically the number one
complaint about Apple's MacBooks and not
only that but the detailed specs and
core counts for the entire M3 family of
chips have just leaked this morning on
Mark German's power on newsletter so let
me go through and explain every little
detail before I get into the insane Ram
details for each chip in the lineup
starting with the M3 this is probably
the most straightforward chip in terms
of the revealed core counts which Mark
Urban discovered from a developer
digging through test logs for all of
these ships the M3 will come with an 8
core CPU made up of four performance
cores and four efficiency cores as well
as as a 10 core GPU so the layout will
be literally identical compared to the
current M2 the main difference will be
the new upgraded cores built on tsmc's
brand new three nanometer chip
technology so we should still get a nice
boost in performance and efficiency and
Apple's also going to bank on the ram
upgrade to really push people to buy and
by the way I do want to mention that the
GPU cores should be getting fully
redesigned this time around using the
same cores as we'll be getting on the
new a17 iPhone chip and we know this
because last year we had a report that
Apple was planning to fully redesign the
graphics course for the a16 chip but
they didn't get it ready in time for
launch so Apple simply reused the same
exact GPU cores from the older a15 which
geeker one on YouTube has already proven
and confirmed by showing the die shots
and efficiency charts so for this year
year we should 100 expect fully
redesigned GPU cores on the a17 and all
of the M3 family at chips hopefully
including Hardware rate tracing as well
now moving on to the M3 Pro chip this is
where it gets very very interesting the
base bin chip that'll be exclusively for
the base 14-inch MacBook Pro is gonna
have 12 CPU cores two more than the base
M2 Pro currently has right now however
instead of adding two more performance
cores Apple will be adding two more
efficiency cores so there's going to be
six performance and six efficiency which
is a bit of a weird combination and
weird Choice from Apple but it's
probably to boost the battery life on
the 14 inch MacBook Pro now you will
have the option to upgrade the chip to
the fully unbinned 14 core version which
is going to add two more performance
cores and that alone is going to provide
a big boost in performance compared to
the current empty Pro and keep in mind
that the base 16 inch MacBook Pro is
going to be coming with the full 14 core
upgraded M3 pro at the base price so
that's very nice and as far as the
graphics the bend model will come with
an 18 core GPU and the upgraded empty
Pro will come with 20. so basically just
one extra core compared to the current
19 core M2 Pro but now let's get into
the big boy the M3 Max chip which is
gonna shake the tech world because of
Apple's very unique approach every
single M3 Max ship even the binned
version is going to be coming with a 16
core CPU which is 33 more cores than the
current M2 Max this detail is incredibly
important because For the First Time
Ever apple is finally giving the max
chip more CPU performance than the pro
chip because for the last couple of
years Apple's match chips didn't have
any CPU performance advantage over the
pro the Mac ships have simply been all
about boosting Graphics power and that's
it and this was incredibly annoying to
users who didn't really care at all
about graphics and would prefer to pay
more for the Mac ship to get more CPU
performance but no apple kept them
identical on that front and the worst
part of all is that some customers who
need CPU performance also need a lot of
ram but to upgrade to more RAM Apple
forces you to pay for the max ship first
to unlock those higher Ram options which
makes it insanely expensive but now the
M3 Max ship will finally have two extra
CPU cores than the M3 Pro but making it
even better the M3 Max doesn't come with
six efficiency cores like the M3 Pro
chip but all only four of them which
means that this new Chip is going to
have a grand total of 12 performance
cores four more than the pro chip which
is basically what you want for
maximizing performance right now the M2
Max only comes with eight performance
cores so the new M3 Max will essentially
have 50 percent more P cores which will
lead to a massive performance increase I
estimated the performance of the M3 Max
ship in a previous video and it hit a
huge twenty thousand twenty four points
in multi-core now being almost as fast
as the current M2 Ultra chip in terms of
real world performance which geekbench 6
does a great job at with its new method
of multi-core testing which has all of
the cores tackle one single large task
which is why the M2 Ultra right now is
suffering from diminishing returns with
its 24 cores and it only scores a little
bit higher than my estimates for the M3
Max and now moving on in terms of the
GPU core counts for the M3 Max it's just
a very small upgrade with 32 GPU cores
for the bin chip and 40 cores for the
upgraded M3 Max and with that said let's
finish up with the final chip in the
lineup the M3 Ultra assuming we don't
get the M3 extreme which honestly with
these core count changes I don't even
know if we'll need an extreme chip the
M3 Ultra will come with a massive 32
cores with 24 of them being performance
cores which is just crazy only having
eight efficiency cores which makes sense
because desktop Macs don't even really
need them and as far as the graphics
you'll have a choice of either 64 GPU
cores or 80 which isn't that big of a
jump compared to what we have now but
it'll still help thanks to the new GPU
Core Design so this Chip is going to
perform incredibly well thanks to the 50
more performance cores and it's likely
gonna kill it in terms of real world
performance compared to Intel and AMD
chips thanks to the unified memory
architecture and speaking of the memory
let's get into the ram leaks for the
first time ever we're expecting all base
M3 Max including the MacBook Air the Mac
Mini and the 13-inch MacBook Pro and
iMac to come with 12 gigabytes of RAM
standard and how do I know this well
there are three good reasons number one
is that Apple gave us a new and curious
Ram option on the current M2 Max
allowing you to upgrade to 24 gigs of
RAM which meant that Apple began
purchasing 12 gigabyte physical RAM
chips from their suppliers number two is
that we actually have confirmation that
Apple's Ram supplier SK High necks made
the shift from 8 gig to 12 gig ram
modules a couple of years ago so they no
longer make eight gigabyte chips anymore
and number three is that the chip spec
for the M3 Max has leaked and it has 48
gigs of RAM which we've never seen
before a big upgrade from the previous
32 gig base Ram so this shows that Apple
has completely moved on from 8 and 16
gigabyte RAM chips to 12 and 24 gig
chips so with that said here are the ram
details for each chip in the lineup the
M3 is going to come with 12 gigs of RAM
allowing you to upgrade to 24. the M3
Pro will come with 24 gigs allowing you
to upgrade to 36 or 48 the M3 Max is
gonna come with 48 allowing you to
upgrade to 96 gigs of RAM and maybe even
up to 144gb X if apple is able to
purchase even larger 36 gig ram modules
but I'm not really sure about that one
and then finally the M3 Ultra which will
come with 96 gigs of RAM allowing you to
upgrade to 192 or potentially up to
288 gigs if the 36 gigabyte RAM modules
will be a thing so now every base Mac of
the lineup will be getting a 50 RAM
boost across the board which is a
massive deal and that's on top of the
performance gains so let me tell you now
the upgrade demand for the M3 family of
Max is going to be so much higher than
the M2 and all I can say is that if you
can wait for the M3 family of Max please
do because they're gonna be insane so
hopefully you enjoyed this video and if
you did subscribe above and check out my
M3 Max performance calculations video
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
foreign